Okay.
Welcome back to Garys Economics.
Today, we're going to predict the next election, and
we are going to answer the question, will Reform win?
Okay.
So whenever I want to make a prediction about politics,
the first thing I always do is I check the odds.
The betting odds are not always right, but I think it's
always a good idea to look at what the market thinks
and then compare it to what you think, and see
if you can understand what the difference might be.
So I look at these odds a lot.
Obviously, I used to be a trader.
I'm looking at the markets a lot.
But I also do, now I'm interested in politics,
look at the betting markets for politics a lot.
So we're going to flash these up here.
I go to Betfair, and I look at the market.
It's a little bit difficult to
translate, so I'll do it for you.
This here shows the betting market for who will
get the most seats at the next UK election.
These two red and blue numbers,
they show, a range of probabilities.
And if you divide one by the
number, you get the probability.
I'll do the maths for you.
What this says is that Reform have almost exactly 50%
chance of getting the most seats at the next election,
and Labour have... That's probably going to be something
like about 32% chance of getting the most seats.
And then you've got the Conservatives
down at... That's going to be about 12%.
And then there's about a 2% chance for the Lib
Dems and a little bit for a few other parties.
So basically, the betting market thinks
that Reform have almost exactly 50% chance of
getting the most seats at the next election.
And that probability has been steadily climbing,
really, over the past few months I've been following it.
Does that mean Reform will win the next election?
Now, this is a little bit more
complicated because in the UK we now have a
multi-party system, which is kind of amazing.
We've never really had one before.
Because the main two historic parties, Labour
and Conservatives, are very unpopular now, we're
going to get a situation in the next election
where really a lot of parties get a lot of seats.
Most seats will go to Reform and Labour, but
the Conservatives will probably still get a few.
The Liberal Democrats will get
a big chunk like they did last election.
And I think the Greens will also get
a decent chunk for the first time ever.
And I think because Labour will be unpopular,
the SNP, the Scottish National Party in
Scotland, will get a lot of seats as well.
Now, the betting market thinks... We can
also ask the betting market whether it
thinks anyone will get an overall majority.
So the way it works in this country
is they'll get a number of seats.
Historically, the winning party almost always gets
a majority, which means more than 50% of the seats.
But because in the next election the vote
will be so divided, there's a good chance that
whoever wins, be it Reform or Labour, who it will
almost certainly be one of those two parties,
neither one will get an overall majority.
So we can also look at the betting market here for
overall majority, and what you see is that the chance
of there being a majority is... They reckon there's
about a 52% chance that we'll have what we call a
hung parliament, which means no one has a majority.
So there's a good chance, according to the
betting market, Reform will get the most seats,
but they will not get enough seats to get a majority.
Which then means there's the possibility
for, like, coalitions, and you could end up
with this really complicated situation where
Reform have more seats, but you would imagine, because
Reform are quite unpopular other than with Reform
voters, that the Liberal Democrats, the Greens, and
the Scottish National Party might support Labour.
Which might give them more seats than Reform, but
then the Conservatives, will they support Reform?
Maybe they will, maybe they won't.
So you could end up in this really complicated, like,
split situation where Reform have the most seats, but as
a coalition, Labour, the Lib Dems, the SNP, the Greens,
have more, and then what will the Conservatives do?
And it could be phenomenally complicated, really.
So basically, when we look at the betting
market, what the betting market tells us is
it's 50/50 Reform will get the most seats, but we
don't know whether that will be enough for them to
get a majority or to form a government.
Okay.
But that is the betting market.
And obviously, as you know, because I talk about
it a lot, I was a former trader, and I was a
very successful trader, and I still do trade now.
When I look at the odds for anything, financial
market, betting market, I'm always asking myself,
"What do I know that the betting market doesn't know?
Could the betting market be wrong?" And I've got
a pretty good track record recently of correctly
predicting politics based really on just one
thing which I know, which political
forecasters generally don't know, which is
that the economy and the economic situation and
living standards are going to keep getting worse.
This is based on the very simple understanding,
which I speak about a lot on this channel,
which is that falling living standards are
linked to rapidly growing wealth inequality.
Our political leaders are not doing
anything about growing wealth inequality, which
means that inequality will continue to grow
and living standards will continue to fall.
Understanding that is basically why I was able to
predict the failure of Rishi Sunak, the failure
of Keir Starmer, and the rising popularity of Reform.
That will keep happening.
Living standards will keep falling, which means that
by the time we get to the next election, and the
next election here in this country is not due until
2029... By the time we get to the next election,
living standards will be even worse than they are now.
The economic situation will be worse, and this will
be basically devastating for the popularity of Labour.
And this is why I think you've seen
Reform's odds rising and rising and rising.
That is basically because the longer Labour are in
power, whilst they do nothing about inequality, it is
basically inevitable that living standards will fall,
their popularity will fall and that will increase
Reform's leads in polling, and that will increase
the Reform's likelihood of winning the next election.
So I think because the economic worsening is not
baked into these statistics, I think Reform's chances
of winning the next election are significantly
higher than the betting market thinks of 50%.
One other thing I should add to that is
when you... If we look historically, this economic
worsening is going to make Labour more unpopular, but
there is a really strong historical trend of at times
of economic weakness, especially prolonged economic
weakness, really strong demand from the public for the
far right, and also for leaders who give a sense
of strength, strong-seeming leaders, especially
leaders who are sort of strong and on our side.
And that is very much the vibe that Farage is going for.
And at the moment, none of the other parties,
none of the other main parties, Conservatives
or Labour, have really been able to do that.
So as the economy weakens, really further
economic weakness is terrible for
Labour and it's just great for Reform.
So I think they have much better chance
than the betting market suggests.
So as that happens, as time passes, Reform's...
Unless Reform do something crazy or there's
some massive scandal, which is definitely
possible because I think there are some
perhaps slightly rogue guys in their party.
If that doesn't happen, I think Reform's
odds will go up and up and up and up and up.
And then that will force the other parties to react.
Because as time passes, it will become more
and more obvious that Labour are going to lose.
The Conservatives are already in a very weak place.
And as it becomes clear they're losing,
they will have to move.
So what will they do?
So Labour... Labour are in interesting situation.
They have a budget coming up in November.
Their economic situation is terrible.
They're probably going to significantly
raise taxes in the autumn.
They're not going to go for popular taxes
like the wealth tax, like taxes we support.
They're probably going
to go on taxes on the middle class.
They might go on taxes on working people.
I think it's going to be very difficult for them
to do that and not take a big hit in popularity.
Then in May, we will have local elections,
Including here in London, and I
think they will do really, really badly.
So I think that Labour are... Firstly,
they're already polling really badly.
Keir Starmer, the leader, polls really badly.
And they're about to go into two like really bad
events basically, a really bad autumn budget
in November, and a really bad election in May.
So, basically, Labour are in a really
bad situation, which is about to worsen.
And what that means is the same thing that
I've said for a long time, because I've
always predicted this would happen to Labour.
Keir Starmer's popularity will collapse.
Labour's popularity will collapse, and Labour
will be forced into a massive rebrand,
which is going to change the leadership.
And we can actually look at this
in the betting markets as well.
So, if we flash it up, you can look at the betting
market, when will Keir Starmer leave?
And if you look at it now, at this point, it thinks that
Keir Starmer will be lucky if he survives next year.
And I think that there is a good
chance that Keir Starmer will go next year.
We don't know for sure it'll be next year.
The betting market here reckons the chance of him
surviving to the next election are about something
like 16%, which is obviously very, very low.
So, we can't say for certain,
but I think I'm pretty confident.
Keir Starmer will go, Keir Starmer will
be replaced, and there'll be a new leader.
Now this... And again, I've said it for even since
before Labour came in that this is what would happen.
This is a massive opportunity for us because there
will be a new Labour leader probably next year.
We don't know exactly when.
And when that leader comes in, he or she will
have to come in with some kind of brand, some
kind of message, some kind of story, right?
They will have to say, "I am Mr. or Mrs. X.
I stand for Y.
My plan for the future of this country is
Z." And in particular, because the economy
continues to worsen, they will have to have a
very clear vision and a very clear picture on
what they were going to do for the economy.
And when they come in, they will have to look around
at all the different ideas about how we should
manage the economy, and they will have to pick one.
And they say, "This is going to
be the brand which identifies me.
This is the kind of economic leader I am.
This is the kind of economic future I want for
the country." And this is going to be a massive,
massive opportunity for me, for us, for this
channel, because I think personally, if you are
a new Labour leader coming in now, and you want to
win the election, the best economic strategy for
you to pick is wealth taxes, is inequality,
Because really, this is the simple
question, is, "What the **** else is there?"
I don't think you can go running on what Labour
and what Keir Starmer have been running on up
till now, which is just, "We are really sensible.
We're going to try and sensible our way out of this.
We're going to try and grow, grow, grow
our way out of this." Because it's really
clear that that is the existing status quo.
That's what governments have tried to do for 20 years.
It hasn't worked.
It's not working.
It's not working for Keir Starmer.
So they have to do something new.
We have to basically position ourselves
that when the new Labour leader comes in, they look
around the world of economic ideas, and they say,
"The one that is going to win us the next election
is inequality, is wealth taxes, is that stuff
supported by Garys Economics and Gabriel Zucman and
Patriotic Millionaires." We have to be that voice.
It's a massive opportunity for us.
If they choose that, I think they can win the
next election, which means I think Reform will
lose the next election. Will they choose it?
So I think it's an obvious choice
I think it's an obvious choice if they want to win.
I don't think Labour are great, so
they might not make the right choice.
There's a couple of other choices they can make.
The other choice is to kind of double down on this
Mr. Sensible, Keir Starmer sensible Labour stuff.
Grow, grow, grow.
It sounds great.
It's... If you're a very boring person, it's...
I don't think it's going to win the public.
It hasn't worked for Keir Starmer.
It didn't work for Biden and Kamala.
It will be very unoriginal, it will be very uninspiring.
I think you're handing the
battle over to the right.
There is another choice they can make, which I think
is a good chance the choice that they will make, which
is to come in very anti-immigration, and that is because
at the moment, the big salience is on immigration.
They're worried about Reform, and they could say,
"Okay, well, we are going to go on the issue which
everybody's talking about, which is immigration." If
they do this, it brings up the issues that I spoke about
in the video from two weeks ago about storytelling and
salience and wedge issues, which is immigration is the
issue upon which Labour is weak and Reform is strong.
So if Labour chooses to make immigration its defining
economic policy, it's basically signing its own death
warrant because it basically guarantees that the entire
economic debate between the new leadership coming in
and the election will constantly be the issue about
which Labour is weak and Reform are strong.
So, basically, I think when the new Labour leader
comes in, he's going to have three choices.
Either move... try and shift salience towards
inequality, distribution, which is the
issue on, on which Labour is strong.
Well, it could try to become strong.
We are strong, and if they try to use our voice,
they could become strong and Reform is weak.
Or it can continue on its sort of nothing, nothing
boring path, which I think is a death warrant.
Or it can choose to aggressively raise the
salience upon which its opponent is strong,
which I think is a failure as well.
If they come to us, I think they can win.
I hope they will.
I'm going to try everything to make sure that they do
That's going to be our main
priority, here on this channel.
Unfortunately, I think they probably
won't, which means I think they'll probably
end up choosing the immigration option, which
means Reform will win the next election.
Okay, so next is the Conservatives.
So the Conservatives are still in there with a chance.
The betting market does think they have a 12% chance
of winning the next election, getting the most seats.
Which is interesting, right?
Because it's not zero.
And at the moment, like there's a
lot of talk "Conservatives are dead."
Their leader is also unpopular despite
the Prime Minister's unpopularity.
They're basically having their space aggressively
usurped by Reform, and it looks like the
party basically is at risk of disappearing.
So why have they got the 12%?
Okay, Reform... Conservatives also... Again,
we can look in the betting market and we can see
betting market thinks the Conservatives will almost
certainly change their leader as well next year.
So we can see here that the... Kemi Badenoch
also less than 50% chance of surviving next year.
They'll bring a new leader in.
It looks like it will be probably Robert Jenrick.
We're not sure.
There's this interesting thing that happens in games,
which is when you are losing a game, especially
when you are losing a game quite aggressively,
being kind of crazy becomes an optimal strategy.
And the reason for that is probably best understood
by looking at it from the flipped perspective,
which is imagine I'm comfortably winning a game.
I know as long as nothing crazy happens,
the game will be predictable and I will win.
So people who are winning want
predictability, which means what people
who are losing want is unpredictability.
And I think as we get closer and closer to that
election, at the moment the Conservatives are
kind of biding their time, thinking about the new
leader, hoping that Reform do something crazy,
**** it up somehow, get like a big scandal.
And then Robert Jenrick is going to come in,
basically again, very hard on immigration
and hope that they can take the place
that Reform lose by sort of ******* it up.
If Reform don't **** it up, as we get closer to the
election, the Conservatives will be more and more in
a situation where they have to do something crazy and
really I'm kind of interested to see what they do.
You will probably see more and more and more kind
of wild and erratic behavior from the Conservatives
as we approach the election because they are
kind of facing basically an existential threat.
There's a good chance that
they will disappear as a party.
And that 12% is basically the 12% chance of, will
the Tories do something crazy which is somehow popular.
I think it's unlikely, but we'll see.
There's a couple of other parties
that I should mention, right?
Which is the Liberal Democrats and the Greens.
If I'm honest, I think the Liberal
Democrat situation is relatively uninteresting.
The Liberal Democrats are... I
don't dislike the Liberal Democrats.
The Liberal Democrats are an interesting
party because they compete not exclusively,
but almost exclusively with the Conservatives.
And that is because their voters are largely richer
people who would otherwise vote for Conservatives.
Because the Conservatives did so badly in the last
election, the Liberal Democrats won like almost all of
their seats that they compete with the Conservatives.
I think they'll probably just do that again.
The big space really at the moment is who fills
the space that has been basically vacated by
the enormous decrease in popularity of Labour.
And that is where the Greens are quite interesting,
which is the Greens now have this new leader, Zach
Polanski, who is making like, quite a conscious pitch,
which is I'm going to fill that space vacated by Labour.
Labour have been sort of moving slowly
right as they sort of try and chase Reform.
Their popularity has collapsed.
And then there's this space which comes up for like,
"Well, we are going to be a party which is like broadly
left." And I've constantly said I think that
there's really a space for a popular party which
focuses the economy, focuses inequality, focuses
wealth tax, and also aggressively focuses on social
media where there's a lot of political power.
And this new guy, Zack Polansky in the Greens, seems to
be... It almost feels like he's just been watching this
channel and he's like, "Yeah, that's a good policy.
I'm going to do that." So it's... I think the Greens
have the potential to take a huge amount of seats.
Because of the massive unpopularity of Labour,
they're like an obvious guys who could fill that gap.
The new leader, Zack Polansky, talks about
30 to 40 seats, which would be enormous for
the Greens, who have never had more than four
seats, which is what they won last election.
It's optimistic, but I think it's possible
for the reason that I highlighted before,
which is Labour's popularity is going to tank.
The risk to the Greens is basically the thing that
we want, which is if the Greens manage to get popularity
on this idea of basically wealth taxes on inequality,
the new leader of Labour might try to usurp that
space, in which case it would really smash the Greens.
But I mean, if what you want is wealth taxes
on inequality, then what you kind of really want
is for the Greens to do this interesting thing
where they push a policy with the hope that Labour
adopt it, which would lead to the Greens losing.
It's this really interesting situation the Greens are
in, which is the best thing they can do for the country
is kind of intentionally lose, because they want to
drag Labour back into a kind of sensible policy space.
And this is... What I think is really interesting here
is that the Greens are now in the kind of situation
that Nigel Farage was in for, like, the last 20 years.
So, Nigel Farage, some people might not know,
he's the leader of the Reform Party, and before
Reform, he was leader of a party called UKIP.
And he only won his first seat
in Parliament last year, in 2024.
But despite that, Nigel Farage is almost
single-handedly the man responsible for Brexit.
And what that means, it's because he has been
doing basically exactly what I suggested the
Greens need to do, which is... He's constantly
been forcing the Conservatives to come towards
his direction without ever winning any seats.
Because he can keep saying, "Well, I'm going to win
4 million, 5 million votes, and you're going to lose
the election unless you come across." And I think
Farage shows what I would like, sort of, the Greens
and Green supporters to realise, which is, under our
kind of stupid political system, where every election
is an election where only two parties can't win,
as a smaller party, it is impossible for you to win.
But it is possible for you to dominate the political
narrative by influencing the main political parties.
And this brings us to... brings me to the next point I
want to make, which is, I think the only way, really,
that I can see Reform not winning this election
is either Labour come across under their new leadership
and they adopt inequality as
their policy message, or the Greens are
so successful that they bring Labour across.
And the truth is, I don't think either of
those things are likely to happen, which
means, that I basically think Reform are
probably going to win the next election.
But if you do want it to happen...
Because I know that a lot of my viewers will
probably not want Reform to win the next election.
If you do want that to happen, if you want
Reform not to win the next election, what do you do?
So I was speaking to my brother this week,
and he... he doesn't like me mentioning him
on the channel, so probably won't be happy.
But he said something.
He's an interesting guy, my brother.
He said something interesting,
which I was speaking to him about.
You know, "Do you think Reform will win the next
election?" And he agreed with me and said, "Probably
yes." And I was like, "Do think there's any way
that Reform could be stopped?" And he just said one
line, which was, "Aggressive and relentless pursuit
of unity and common ground." That's all that he said
This is the kind of thing that he says.
And in a sense, that's what I've just
said, which is basically unless the Greens
and Labour, the party on the left and the party of
the centre, both move into this space of focus
on the economy, focus on inequality, deal with
taxation, then Reform will win the election.
And at this point, I should probably also
mention there is obviously a third party.
There's the, the new party, which doesn't have a name
yet, which is led by Corbyn and Sultana, which...
They're behind wealth taxes as well, right.
These guys have also popped up.
The truth is we are going into the next election,
Reform will be strong favorites.
And really, whether Reform win or not will be decided
by whether these different groups of people, these
different groups of voters are able to do,
as my brother said... He's going to hate
me from keeping on mentioning him.
Aggressive and relentless pursuit
of unity and common ground.
It's as simple as that, basically.
We have, especially in this country, a political
system which aggressively punishes division.
Aggressively, aggressively punishes division.
What will probably happen in the next election
is that Reform will win an overall majority
with the smallest ever number of votes that
any party has ever won an overall majority.
And that will be simply because
the people and the politicians in this
country who do not support Reform are divided.
We have a political system, first past the post,
which as an aside, I think is a stupid political system.
Maybe I'll talk a video about it one time.
That voting system, that political system aggressively,
aggressively, aggressively punishes division.
So whether Reform win or not is basically a
question of will the centre and will the left
be able to be aggressive and relentless
in their pursuit of common ground?
And, I would love for them to unite on the issues
which they have in common, which I would like to
believe are fixing the economy...... dealing with
inequality, dealing with an unfair taxation system.
In reality, I don't think these various
groups are going to be able to do that.
And unfortunately, that's just simply because
there's a lot of bad blood and a lot of antipathy
between the centre and the left,
and that goes in both directions.
If they are able to be sensible, get their heads
together, focus on the message that will win,
which is inequality, distribution, the economy,
focus aggressively on their common ground, try
to avoid bickering and raising the salience
of their differences, try to avoid raising the
salience of their opponents, then they can win.
If they're divided, they will lose.
Okay, so that's my prediction.
I do think Reform will win the next election.
I think that will be clearer as time goes on.
Really, the big dice that is yet to roll
is Labour's rebrand and Labour's new leadership.
And in particular, what they
choose as their economic message.
I've been talking to Labour.
I'm not that popular.
I'm... They're not
that popular with me either.
I don't think that much of them, but I say that.
Like, I want them to win because I think we have a
much better chance of getting wealth taxes with them
than with Reform, but I don't think that they will.
I think they will...
I think they'll kind of **** it up.
I think they'll probably choose migration.
I think they'll end up
just boosting the salience of their opponents.
And I think Reform and Farage
will win the next election.
So, what do we think about that?
Now, this is quite difficult to talk about, right?
Because I try really, really hard on
this channel to be non-politically partisan.
I am a single-issue channel.
I'm an economist.
I think the issue is inequality, and it's
about wealth taxes, so how do we do that?
And I try my best and I genuinely want this
channel to be watched by people on all sides of the
political spectrum, including Reform voters.
And the country is becoming so divided at the moment
between people who like Farage and Reform and people
who don't, that it's very difficult to send a message
that will reach and be listened to all my viewers.
Because I know we're listened to
by people who are on both sides of this.
So, I'm going to send... I'm going to try to split
my message up into basically two parts.
One for people who don't want Reform to win and
then one for people who are maybe supporting Reform.
Okay, so if you don't want Farage to win, and again
we're going to have to split this message up now between
the people in the centre, people who might...
if you want to know who's on the centre, it's, you know.
Do you like Keir Starmer?
Do you like the current Labour Party?
Do you like Tony Blair?
You know, these kind of people
who like that kind of status quo.
What do we want to say to them?
And then we're going to talk to people
on the left, so people who might like
Zach Polanski, might like Jeremy Corbyn.
What do we... What are the
risks to both of these groups?
Okay.
If you're on the centre, and you
want... Presumably you want Labour to win.
The way that you will lose this next election
is by either persisting with a status quo
economic policy which has no salience, no cut
through, no narrative, or by moving aggressively
towards constantly talking about immigration and
aggressively raising the salience of your opponents.
You need a message which is
different from Reform's message.
If your message is Reform's message,
Reform will win the next election.
So, that's it.
You need your own message.
You need your own voice.
You need something that's popular.
And I'm building it for you here.
If you want to win the next election and
you're on the centre, you don't need to
change your opinions on everything, but you
do need to be open to doing something on
inequality, on wealth taxes, on the economy.
You want to be saying, "We're going to raise
taxes on the super rich so that we can cut tax
on workers." That will boost your economy.
That will make you popular.
That is how you win.
And I want you to be really, really mindful
of that when you're thinking about who is the
next Labour leader and what should he support?
Now, if you're on the left, I think the real risk
to the left at this point is with the real growth,
the aggressive growth in the popularity
of Farage and Reform and things like the march
which happened last weekend, I think there is a
risk that the left gets very, very angry and starts
to be really, really aggressive and accusatory
towards people who might be voting for Reform.
I want to show you a clip which I
saw on PoliticsJOE the other weekend.
So, let's run it.
This is PoliticsJOE, talking to some
Reform, you know, passionate supporters,
people who've gone to the conference.
Let's see what they're saying.
Wealth tax or no wealth tax?
It's a very hard one.
I mean, I come from a working class town.
Everything in kind of Reform's policies would
maybe leaning more towards no wealth tax.
So, for me, if the wealth tax was possible, I'm at a
stage in my politics where I would actually support it.
There are a lot of Reform voters
who'd be supportive of wealth taxes.
I know that a lot of people are scared of
the growth of Reform, and the truth is, I
am scared of the growth of Reform as well.
I know that a lot of people who watch this channel
who see themselves as from the left are probably
people who are very interested in politics,
people who are very knowledgeable about politics.
Just the very fact that you're here watching
this video means you are probably somebody who is
interested in and knowledgeable about politics.
I would like you to understand that the vast majority
of people in this country are not experts in politics.
They read very little about politics.
They have not spent loads and loads
of time thinking and researching politics.
And they get their information from
the media or from social media.
And what they have been told and are being told
consistently in the media is that the reason you are
poor, the reason your kids can't get a house, the
reason you can't get a job is because of immigration
or because of illegal immigration, because of refugees.
That's what they're being told.
They're being told that again and
again and again and again and again.
So, this is where they are.
This is what they think.
This is what they're being told.
They think that the reason they're
being poor is because of immigration.
And if they go to a protest or, you
know, they speak online about this and
somebody gets in their face and calls them
a racist, that's not going to win them over.
You are not going to win
these people over like that.
I totally understand the instinct of people on the
left to worry about increasing racism in society.
I think it's happening.
I can feel it happening. You need to
be pragmatic, you need to be sensible.
If you want to get progressive change in the next
election, you need to win people over, and I think
you need to be really careful to resist the temptation
to go around shouting at people, calling them racists.
Listen, there are racists in this country.
There always have been racists in this country.
There's always been 100,000, 200,000 people who vote
for the BNP and might have been voted by racism.
Might have been... Sorry, motivated by racism.
Reform are going to win the next election,
and you are not going to stop that by
turning around and calling people racists.
What you need to do... And I know this might not be
pleasant for some of you... I think my brother's right.
You need to be relentless and aggressive in your
pursuit of common ground and unity, and that means
you're willing to go to people who you might not
agree with everything about and say, "Listen, I
know we don't agree on everything, but let's find
the thing that we do agree on, and let's fight
for that." Because those people at those protests,
they, just like you, are struggling to pay the rent.
Their kids are struggling to pay the rent.
They're struggling to find economic futures.
If you centre that, if you focus on
that, you can build something positive.
You can win them over.
If you focus on what divides you, all you're going
to do is make this country more and more divided.
So that, that's it, you know.
I think really, in politics,
as in history, division loses.
I think you can afford to find your differences
and fight over them when you are winning.
If you are losing, you need to find unity.
And it's as simple as that, basically.
If people on the left and on the centre
are able to be aggressive and relentless in
their pursuit of common ground, they can win,
and I think that common ground is the economy.
I think it's inequality.
I don't see any other way of stopping Reform.
So, if that's what you want to do, if you want
to stop Reform, if you want to see a more equal
country, you need to focus on that in your arguments.
Find that common ground.
Focus on your common ground and
unity when you speak to other people.
So I'm going to have a word for people who
want Reform to win, but before that, I just want to
talk a little bit about what happens if Reform do win.
And I know we have viewers all over the country.
It's not just Reform here, because the far-right
are winning and are about to win all over the world.
You know, my big concern if Reform win
is not actually really Farage and Reform.
It's not, it's not the current far-right.
I know these guys get called fascists
and they get called racists.
I don't think they are all fascists and racists.
My big concern is that when Reform get into
power, the same thing will happen to Reform
as what happened to Labour, what happened
to Rishi Sunak, what has happened to Trump.
Even what happened to Biden.
What has happened to basically every
politician and political party in the last 15 years.
They come in.
They don't deal with the fundamental economic
problem, which is growing inequality.
Living standards worsen, and then they find themself
in the same situation Rishi Sunak and Keir Starmer
found themselves in, which is like, "Okay, we're in.
We're failing on the economy.
We're super unpopular.
We need to roll the dice.
We need to rebrand.
What do we do?" And you have this situation here
where Labour are kind of stuck in the centre, and when
you're in the centre, you don't really know where to go.
I said this about Trump before you came
in, and I think it's proving true,
and I'll say the same about Reform.
It's when they come in, their
economic policies aren't working.
The obvious political move is to say, "This is because
we are not going far enough on immigration." I think
it's a... It's just the re- It's just so... And you
can say, "Look, it's because we're being blocked.
Labour are blocking us, or the courts are blocking us,
or the European Court of Human Rights are blocking
us, or the academics are blocking us, or the lefties
are blocking us, or The Guardian's blocking us." And
you can say, "The reason that the economy is not
working is because we are not being aggressive enough
on immigration." So, at the moment, the emphasis
is on illegal immigration or asylum seekers.
And, okay, you leave the European... You
leave the European Court of Human Rights,
you know, the Convention on Refugees, and
you say, "The UK doesn't accept any refugees.
Done." That's not going to fix the economy.
I guarantee you.
I'll bet you any money that will not fix the economy.
Then you say, "Okay, well, you know, the
reason for that is because, you know, that
was just one part of migration, you know?
Look at all the enormous amounts of legal migration,
and legal migration is much, much, much bigger
than asylum seeking." So, okay, we need to get
rid of legal migration, and if you do that,
that's not going to fix the economic problems.
So, you get rid of legal migration.
You're still not fixing the economic problem.
What do you do next?
Well, the obvious place to go next is to
say, "Well, that wasn't enough because we've
already had too much migration" right.
So you go back and you look at people who have recently
migrated in the last five years, in the last 10
years, and you say, "Okay, we need to get rid
of recent migrants." You know, these people
might be British citizens in many cases.
They might have permanent residency.
So you start to kick out recent... recent migrants.
What if that doesn't work?
You know, what... My real concern is
this can keep going further and then
you can start scapegoating more groups.
You know, there was a clip online.
Did you see that clip with the American...
with the Fox News anchor saying he
thinks we should kill homeless people?
[Jack] What?
[Gary] Let's get this one up.
Okay.
Yes, there was a clip on the
right-wing American station recently,
Fox News, where they're talking about how to
deal with the problem of homelessness.
This is, you know, this is not the future.
This is today.
Either you take the resources that we're going to
give you and... Or you decide that you gotta be locked
up in jail, that's the way it has to be now.
Or involuntary lethal injection- Yeah or something.
Just kill 'em.
Yeah, Brian, why did it have to get to this point?
Right?
You know, the... I think this...
That really happened, by the way.
This is a really genuine thing that happened
in the US, which is a Fox News host
suggested that the way to deal with the problem of
homelessness is to execute all the homeless people.
So, I... And I'm not... Listen, I'm not saying that
Farage wants this, you know, and I'm not saying even
that Trump wants this, but, when your plan to deal with
the economy is to scapegoat a group of people, and
then you hit that group of people, you kick them out of
the country and it doesn't work, and you're unpopular,
the obvious thing to do next is to go harder.
And you're seeing this now in... You're seeing on the
biggest news channel in the US, anchors suggesting
the thing to do is to murder all the homeless people.
Listen, I'm not saying Farage wants to do that, right?
I'm an economist.
I think Farage will win the next election.
They will fail on the economy.
The obvious political move will to be...
be to go further, and I am very, very worried
about where this could go in the end.
And I would like that hopefully to
sharpen your mind, both if you want
Farage to win and if you don't want Farage to win.
But listen, if they win, I think we do need to be
ready for this because I think they probably will win.
There would also be massive political opportunity,
which is the sense that, at the moment, Farage has
the phenomenal strength of never having been in
power, which means that he cannot be blamed for
any of the economic weaknesses that the UK is in.
Because the Conservatives were
in for 14 years, they failed.
Labour have been in for a year, they
are failing and will keep failing.
And he has this ability to say, "Well, I have this
magic bullet and it's going to work." When he comes
in, just as Trump has just come in, living standards
will keep falling and we need to be ready to say what
I've always said, which is, "This is what will happen
if you don't deal with inequality." Until and unless
we have a powerful and cohesive narrative, a
powerful story, which I think should be about
inequality and about billionaires, the only
political space, because the centre is obviously
failing, will be to go further and further Right.
Okay.
Now, I want to go on to
the people who want Reform to win.
I went on LBC yesterday, on Tom
Swarbrick's show, I did a live phone in.
And, somebody called in and he said... he said
that he wa- he's a fan of the channel, so he might be
out there watching today, and he says he enjoys
the videos and he enjoys the stuff that we put out.
But he said to me, "You're not going to win
because what I care about is immigration and,
and there's millions of us in this country
that what we care about is immigration.
And maybe not you," talking to me, "Maybe not
you, Gary, you don't maybe do this, but your
supporters, they turn around to us and
they call us bigots and they call us racists.
And I'm not a racist, I just...
I'm just worried about immigration.
I want there to be less immigration."
This is what this guy said to me.
And I just want to make it very, very clear
because I know probably if you are a Reform
voter, you might be hearing things online about
me, that I'm a radical leftist or whatever.
There is a space for you here.
I do this for you.
Not just only for you, but I do this for all of the
hardworking men and women in this country and across
the world who see their living standards falling.
Okay?
I know it's broken, I know it's not working, and I
know when you look at the politicians around you,
you see a lot of people who think you're pretty ****.
And if honest... if I'm honest
I think the same thing as you.
I understand that.
And that's exactly why I do what I do.
I walked away from a lot of money to do this
because I could see the way the country was going.
I know that there's not a lot of
great political leaders out there.
I don't trust the guys that are leading it.
They are very, very wealthy people.
They're funded by very, very wealthy people.
Their plan is to cut the taxes of very, very wealthy
people and to fund that by cutting your public services,
your education, the NHS, the things that you need.
That's not going to work out well for you and your kids.
There's a space for you here.
I don't take sides.
I'm an economist.
I do what I do for the future of this country,
for the future of ordinary people like you,
families like yours, your kids, your grandkids.
I'm a very good economist.
I've got a very good track record.
I've got a lot of educational videos, which
I'll put up here for free, which you can watch
for free to understand what's happening.
If you do not deal with growing inequality, the
living standards of your kids and your grandkids
will get worse and worse and worse and worse.
There's a space for you here.
And I know when I, when I say that, that I don't
trust your leaders, you're going to turn around and
you're going to point to Keir Starmer and you're
going to say, "Well, I don't trust him either."
And the truth is, I agree with you.
I wish we had more good political leaders.
And at the moment, maybe we don't.
I'm working hard to build that
and I would like your support.
We're building something here that's
going to put more money in your pocket, that's
going to mean your kids can have homes.
But there's something else I need say as well.
Listen, I'm from London and I grew up in a very
multicultural place with lots of people, lots of
different colours, lots of different countries.
And last weekend, I had friends who were scared to leave
the house, were scared to walk on the streets of London.
And that's because they think you're racists.
That's what they think.
And I tell those people that, "You're not all racists.
That a lot of you are just worried about the
future of this country." And they don't believe me.
So I need you to prove me right.
If it's about immigration and it's
not about racism, keep saying that.
And if you see racists in your movement,
you need to do something about that.
Because these economic problems that we're seeing
in our country of growing inequality, falling living
standards, unaffordability of housing, I guarantee you
right now, they are affecting people on both sides.
And I guarantee you right now, if you guys are
not able to aggressively find your common ground
and unity, that division will tear this country
apart and will destroy the living standards
for your futures, your kids and your grandkids.
So listen, that's my final message.
I don't like doing this schoolteacher ****.
I don't know if it's going to work.
But, if you're divided, you will lose.
And I'm not saying that just to the
Right, I'm not saying that just to
the Left, I'm saying that to everyone.
If you are divided, you will lose.
Every single year, the richer get richer.
Every single year, the rich get richer
and richer and richer and richer.
And ordinary people lose their homes.
And ordinary families can't
afford to have kids, you know.
Can't afford to turn the heating on.
That is what happens.
If you're divided, you will lose.
If you are divided, you will lose.
You will spend your time fighting each other
and the rich will take everything.
You're going to need each other.
Don't forget that.
Tax wealth, not work.
Thank you very much.